economía en france 24 está conmigo en el
estudio daniela hablando daniela muy
buenas noches vamos a comenzar hablando
de colombia qué significa para este país
que haya perdido el grado de inversión
hola santiago buenas noches voy a
explicar lo de la siguiente manera en el
mercado financiero mundial las tres
calificadoras de riesgo más importantes
son moody's fitch ratings y standard and
poor's esta última le acaba de quitar a
colombia el grado de inversión que
ostentó por más de una década estas
notas miden básicamente la capacidad de
pago de las deudas y de eso depende que
haya o no inversiones en el país pero
dejemos que sea un exministro de
hacienda a quien nos lo expliquen mejor
el efecto inmediato es que una de una
salida de fondos y la tasa de cambio
probablemente se devaluó el efecto más
de largo plazo es crear una
incertidumbre en el sentido de que el
gobierno tiene que demostrar que puede
pagar muy bien su deuda para eso tiene
que demostrar que puede pasar una
reforma tributaria que puede disminuir
sus gastos pero las circunstancias
actuales que puede generar paz
en las calles y aclaremos lo siguiente
la decisión de standard impulso no es
por la situación política actual sino
porque por el contrario ve muy necesaria
una reforma tributaria para recaudar más
impuestos pero pues colombia no es la
única tampoco está mal para ante las
calificadoras escuchemos los países de
la región están muy volcados ha habido
13 disminuciones en calificación en
muchos países de los países que han
hecho impago argentina y ecuador quiere
decir que este problema no es sólo por
donde su prueba generalizada en américa
latina' iba a ser generalizado en el
mundo porque saliendo de un año de
pandemia todos los gobiernos están con
muchos gastos y con pocos ingresos más
claro imposible de daniela pasemos ahora
a hablar de las casas de cambio en cuba
que operan en los aeropuertos de ese
país que se quedaron sin divisas así
desde santiago hasta ahora los viajeros
que salían de cuba podían comprar hasta
200 dólares o su equivalente en otras
monedas o la tasa oficial que es de 24
pesos cubanos por cada dólar aunque la
divisa en el mercado informal ya se
cotiza a poco más del doble
pero la pandemia redujo drásticamente la
entrada de turistas y por eso no hay
suficientes dólares para vender los
aeropuertos son los únicos lugares en
los que se podían comprar legalmente
divisas extranjeras presentando una
tarjeta de embarque y el pasaporte ya
que los bancos no venden desde hace
meses pasamos ahora méxico que logró un
récord de inversión extranjera buenas
noticias una buena noticia los casi 12
mil millones de dólares en inversiones
que ingresaron en el primer trimestre
del 2021 son el mayor monto recibido
para un primer trimestre desde que
comenzaron los registros en 1999 según
el gobierno también representan un
aumento del 14,8 por ciento frente a
hace un año cuando la cifra quedó casi
igual a la de 2019 este récord llega
después de que en 2020 la inversión
extranjera directa se desplomara en casi
12 por ciento por culpa por supuesto de
la pandemia
por sectores santiago manufacturas y
servicios financieros fueron los mayores
receptores y por países eeuu contribuyó
con más del 40 por ciento y le siguieron
españa siguió a españa
daniela que lo que está pasando en
mexico perdón en canadá que temen por
una posible burbuja inmobiliaria pues
que el banco central dijo que los
precios han crecido en alrededor del 30
por ciento en lo que va de la pandemia
el fenómeno que está ocurriendo es el
siguiente santiago armados de ahorros
algunos hogares han contraído más deuda
hipotecaria y la proporción de lo que
pagan frente a sus ingresos es más alta
que antes todo combinado con menores
tasas de interés eso ha hecho que suba
la demanda y que la oferta se quede
corta el banco central hace un llamado a
los ciudadanos para que sean más
prudentes al asumir nuevas deudas ya que
los recientes aumentos de los precios de
las viviendas no son normales y advierte
incluso que sin que hubiera una
situación como la actual algunos de los
factores que hicieron que los precios
que subieran rápidamente podrían
revertirse más adelante los precios en
toronto y montreal están sobrevalorados
y ottawa está siguiendo la misma
tendencia y lo que le da un tinte de
burbujas que muchos están comprando no
para vivir precisamente sino a la espera
de que los precios sigan subiendo
indicadores cómo les fue a las bolsas en
la jornada
la bolsa de nueva york que subió después
de conocerse que las peticiones de ayuda
por desempleo bajaron de las 500 mil la
semana pasada el mismo dato hizo que las
bolsas europeas rebotaron desde las
pérdidas del día anterior y las bolsas
latinoamericanas siguieron en la estela
de wall street con excepción de colombia
por obvias razones
gracias daniela por esta actualización
del mundo de la economía es todo por el
momento aquí en france24 siga con
nosotros
[Música]